I just don't think people believe me I
think 99.9 your country is not the
variable of your hustle my friend now
the environment then like
entrepreneurship is glorified in the US
the UK wants to be more reserved
differently you know but your hustle
your work ethic your drive is not
predicated on your zip code so first of
all it's different for everyone but this
whole notion of like where's the time
I'm just I just think people are loaded
with excuses I think that the
vaynernation thinks they're hustling and
strength your face like if 99.9% of you
are not everybody has time stop watching
[ __ ] lost the thought and nature of
like people saying well America is an
entrepreneurial paradise is the same
conversation that's happening within
America I'd like to be great in tech you
need to be in San Francisco let me just
remind everybody that Facebook was
invented in Boston just working the
people don't have patience there's so
many people giving up I think the fear
of losing Trump's excitement so many
people so to me hustle will be putting
all your effort into achieving the goal
at hand and for me that means making
every minute count
look you need a break good get your
break but the bottom line is every
minute that you can apply to your game
you need to I worry that people don't
tap into their strengths I think that
people like to claim that they work hard
and smart but they're not putting in the
work and they work 9:00 to 6:00 it's
just not enough execute is the way it
always is following the school business
[Music]
your talent isn't enough you've got to
go put in the work and have a thick skin
do to help noxious ly thick my skin is
you could punch me in the face 8,000
times I'm here to get punched
whether you're a hundred or zero you
want to sin and live in a mountain with
no technology or you want to buy the
Jets and hustle your face off or
anything in between you need to find
your cadence there is no reason just do
[ __ ] you rate not promise me you want
whatever you wish to do do it look
yourself in the mirror and ask yourself
what do I want to do every day for the
rest of my life do that and then hustle
your face on 15 hours a day to get
people to care you know what I also
about I also about meeting every single
person on earth do you know why because
I care about people more about myself
you're spending an hour - on things
every day that aren't achieving this
extra brand or extra money that you're
chasing - do you need to work so hard
and your talent isn't enough you've got
to go put in the work and the fact the
matter is we're in a time and in a
generation that's not willing to do that
so I have eggs sure call them out myself
every day unless six or seven Peter's
telling everybody I'm gonna find the
Jets if you want bling bling if you want
to buy the Jets if you want to hit work
that's how you get
hustle is putting it all on the line
period simple you know like the way it
sounds
buckets because it's the truth because
you're just not working also is waking
up one day the day before you die and
realizing you gave it your all into the
parenting of your children the building
of your businesses the four lamp three
that you wanted to do whatever you
define it's just you know all in
emotionally and executional II in theory
and strategy and an execution hustle is
a word to so many people even to some of
my hardcore fans I'm sorry to call you
out but I follow you like you follow me
and people talk about the hustle but
then you're talking about your six
o'clock you know happy hour drink or
your video game or this and that
and here we are in holidays and
everybody's going to their holiday party
and I've got one meeting coming up right
now two meetings after that we're doing
all my email and so while everybody's
trinkets of goddamn eggnog I continue
the hustle and so you can say it or you
can do it but I highly recommend you do
both stop crying and just keep hustling
hustle is the most important word ever
[Music]